taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to the hey folks welcome to
t-a-s-e-e buds it's a beautiful day in
New York City it is a beautiful day you
were ill yesterday and then we thought
you might have also gotten the Believe
It or Not covid which by the way I know
six people will have it now and by the
way the people like covered covered this
isn't a like it's it's it still is the
code like it tests positive for covert
so it's what I have yeah I know I'm
saying I care or believing or don't or
the you know it's a good spirit like
people get so [__] heated people why
are you mentioning's been gone really
because I [__] tested positive for it
and I was out for the count people do
call it whatever you want I was sick I
was terrified that I had coveted because
I was staying I was away and I was
staying with a friend while I was away
and while I was away I was my allergies
were really bothering me but my friend
his mother lives with him
and when I went to leave she had been so
hospitable and the last day I was
leaving my allergies really bothering me
and she was like it was so nice having
you she was so sweet and I said I'm not
gonna hug you
just in case my allergies are cold yeah
you still don't want to take out any old
folk and she goes she goes oh it doesn't
matter come here and hug me anyway
[Laughter]
Jesus
but I I'm sorry I just spilled my drink
all over me to check today's box I'll
tell you that uh I'm wet for the whole
episode then
I was in a good mood I could tell you
that that's not a hex you hastily open
that and barely touched your lips with
it can I tell you something my hands my
hands are all Lord this morning that
already happened to me with my green
juice with my uh with my athletic greens
and I said all right there's a spill for
today now I'm doubling up on it I think
you're just not paying attention and
just pouring
think that I'm not paying attention
every day that I spill a drink on myself
it's a lighthouse I gotta tell you dude
you're you're a little bit scattered all
right and that's not experiences
am I scattered every time I take a sip
of a bed we were just out in the lobby
thing the kitchen area excuse me you
said can you hand me too I you
specifically requested two drinks in the
fridge I handed you both drinks and then
you walked away forgetting that you had
even asked me for them no no I said Sal
your two drinks and you had to turn
around and go back I'll tell you what
happened in my head in my head I was
about to lead to go to the bathroom and
I thought you were going to walk back
with them and so when I exited without
them I I was ahead of you I was walking
ahead of you Joe I don't know that very
drink you just spilled on yourself was
to drink requested uh yeah but anyway so
I was stay okay so my my friend's mom
very sweet and she was like she goes oh
stop it it doesn't matter and hugged me
and I was like she's probably right it's
just allergies and got home and then I
got home and I felt fine Monday night
when I got home and then I woke up
yesterday and I was like oh my God I am
so sick and I was I I just was like uh
here it is here it is I'm gonna have
covid yeah I at shorted it to my
friend's mom I will show you how to
because I two people we called through
were fill in for me in case I was sick
have it yeah and I was like you got to
be kidding me it's going around I mean
look but I know what happens what is a
severe cold a flu of ice cold whatever
you want but I don't want to get other
people sick right that's what we had to
well that's all we had to postpone the
live stream yes and you know what it is
it's wet it's a new reschedule date is
Wednesday May 31st
uh a couple of changes 9 p.m Eastern
Time everything's the same on your end 9
p.m Eastern all the tickets are honored
for those of you who couldn't make May
10th uh I ended up getting ill and we
had to postpone it to Wednesday night 9
pm May 31st this is the first ever live
stream taste buds in case you've been
living under a rock you can get tickets
uh in the link of this video you can get
tickets on any of our social Pages links
or go to moment.co moment like in the
moment dot Co slash taste buds right
yes uh
moment.co and we have
something that's also where you go if
you need if you can't attend yeah if you
want to refund you need a refund or
whatever but let me tell you the show of
support has been fantastic guys and uh
if you couldn't make it if you didn't
realize when it was if you this is the
first time you're hearing of it May 31st
you can still get tickets we have a lot
of surprises planned still some really
funny surprises yes about I mean a
handful of guests yes some big surprise
guests hopefully and uh and then the
battle we're keeping on the wraps until
then but it's a good one no one has any
idea who's gonna win oh and then the
special merch is going to be available
too that's right ordered a limited run
of these specialty taste buds shout outs
to the artist let's plug the artist down
below pimp uh who made this she's really
wonderful uh shout outs to her you may
remember the I'm hating it uh Ronald
that this came out we tweeted this a
while yeah she did that I loved it so
much we asked her to add me thematically
into the picture yeah I'm the little boy
here as you can see so Joe and I are
going to sign these uh and and number
them we're going to sign him a number
because there's only there's only a
certain amount I think 200 or 250 or
something 150 or 200 yeah yeah um we're
gonna sign them datum or number them and
uh they are gonna go on sale during the
live stream you'll be able to buy them
um in the link of the live stream and
then you know and then after that week
but once they're sold out they're gone
and we are hand uh hand numbering these
ourselves also one last thing about the
live stream it's gonna go it's gonna go
to it will be available in demand
uh the following week yeah and then
that's it that's that this is that's it
that's a good point and this is the only
time you'll ever not not ever but but
first time ever you'll be able to watch
the episode and vote in real time while
you're watching the argument and that's
it for this episode like that this
episode will be live streamed and then
it'll be available in demand and then
that's it yeah if you're not in it
you're not gonna see it uh this was
probably a
biggest episode yeah I would say so so
yeah so and then other people were
asking like oh I can't do it that night
well the ticket is good for after that's
one week on demand like Joe said so you
have the whole week to watch it watch it
again
um and then after that that's it it's
not being put up so this is the only way
to join us and see this thing yeah and
it'll be fun and uh and it'll be a big
episode too so we realize people buying
tickets you're you're paying for a
ticket we appreciate that we're gonna
give you a bit some bang for your buck
don't worry yeah but we've also it's not
going to be two and a half years of free
well that too and we don't have a
patreon we don't ask for anything I know
I don't want to bring it up we also have
a regular merch if you want to go on a
point it's not going to just be us
sitting on this couch you know we're you
know what I mean we're delivering oh for
sure it'll be us sitting but but we're
gonna do it we're really getting into it
um and also actually I just found out
that our merch uh our merch is low and
so if you have never gotten Merchant the
designs that we have out right now are
nearing their end of their run and uh
that'll be the that's the only time you
can get that first run of merch and then
we will once that's out we will start a
new speaking of speaking of I'm hating
it I want to go back to the sick thing
in a minute but speaking of I'm hating
it
do you smell the smell coming through
the window that smells like burgers and
fries
yes I do smells McDonald's eat does it
not or Wendy's ish
it smells
I think I smelled something when I
walked into the smell but I've regulated
good dude it smells like burger with
ketchup
you
am I wrong no it's probably like a it's
probably something
it's probably what are you gonna say I
would no I just you
you somewhere
in your life
McDonald's
got their hooks into you big now I don't
know if I don't know if it's a if it's a
bigger conspiracy than we even know like
someone injected you with something to
make you fiend for it and smell it at
all times I feel like if you were having
a stroke or a heart attack you'd smell
McDonald's not toasted bread not burnt
bread no but or I think maybe something
you don't I would love to talk to you
like and and and pinpoint
when McDonald's became your savior I can
tell you
that as a child
there was no food on Earth I liked more
period
uh it's tough to be when you're a kid
let me let me take you through the steps
uh or the moments I birthday party every
year at McDonald's hands down
I remember you did have that yes I went
to him I never had one of my own I had
them so you had the characters and stuff
oh uh I I honestly I can't remember if
they had the character I mean that's I
think that's the we had our big selling
point unless you had yeah I did but we
have the play place
this is pre-play Place dude play place
was kind of later in the in the yeah
I was young enough to to have enjoyed it
at a time but like I'm talking like
since I was a little little kid like
we'd have my birthday lunch or dinner
there's no more McDonald's are there any
more McPlay places do you even know
where to McPlay places okay I I mean I
don't know if those went away they would
germ they would germ uh friggin yeah
they were they were gross
but there was a bull pit in my in our
main McDonald's well not Maine we have
like 21 with the main one uh that I went
to when I was a kid it was a ball pit
that was unmatched
I mean it was it was big in size and and
and they let There was really no rules
they let you go bad [__] in that what I
liked big more than the ball pit was the
uh the mayor mcchees uh jail Tower they
had where you could crawl up into his
head and look out through the bar yes I
really enjoyed is that the mayor or was
that the policeman because that's why
the policeman well wait who was the
policeman I don't remember it wasn't his
head a cheeseburger I thought no that's
geez was there a police constable
constable
I think yeah there he is yeah it was
that's that's him he has a big
cheeseburger head oh officer Big Mac Oh
[__] no that's a good rap name
that is a good rap day uh
um no that's uh
yeah you could remember you could climb
up into his head yeah I loved it yeah
that was it was like okay it was a
little yeah you went up through the
middle you had to be careful but then
you got up there and you sat up that you
felt like you were in the Statue of
Liberty yeah it was that was amazing
there he is there it is wow awesome that
looks oh you guys throw the pimp because
this is bringing back big memories whoa
where was an outdoor McPlay place oh my
mine was outdoor oh mine was indoor I
never even saw an indoor one oh rain or
shine big
it didn't matter yeah mine was yeah look
at that frightening thing that's that's
it how's that looks like it literally
looks like a a one of the things you
burn on a lawn but
but I'll tell you again Burning Man the
outdoor particularly got crush
yeah because now it was the elements the
elements right and they're not washing
those balls they're not there's no way
to wash them they're not washing them
they don't remove them and put them back
and nobody goes in there and cleans them
Ball by ball which means that if that
thing was there for 10 years then every
kid with a snot on his nose coughing
hacking licking those balls if you think
about it right now they probably had to
get rid of the 80s dude they probably
have to get rid of it because of like a
get out now look how look how short that
is I swear to God I thought it was 12
feet in the air at least you don't think
that's a short one wait where is that
one in no man's land this guy bought the
stuff no he didn't put it on his own
problem no he did not holy [__] this guy
bought a mayor this guy bought a officer
Big Mac jail Tower and put it in his
yard that's straight gangster yeah
that's awesome I would want that in my
yard are you kidding I gotta tell you
the thought never crossed my mind until
I'm seeing it here yeah now I want to do
it I bet you I bet you there's a bunch
of those laying around in a warehouse
somewhere that we can get our hands I
bet it's you I bet you they're more
attainable than you would think we
should get one and do a podcast live
from the inside this is me laying in a
circle I'll tell you what I would you
know what I would do if I had if I had a
big yard with like a pool
and I could I would do this I'd erect
the McDonald's the golden arch sign the
illuminated red so I would see
something's wrong with you but don't you
think that would look awesome in your
backyard next to your pool arches
you tell me you don't think what does
that to do with the pool I'm saying if I
had a backyard with like a pool area
like you know where you dress it up I'd
put the the skinny pole with the
illuminated McDonald's sign you mean the
one that's like billion served the one
that like on the street the the sign
that stands in front of the restaurant
you would put that sign in your yard
yeah you don't think that would look
awesome
as a yard decoration having conflicting
feelings because I think at least some
officer Big Mac is
meant to be in a play like like is has a
function you're telling me night time
you're by the pool lit pool dark dark
lit pool above you is a glowing red and
white red and yellow McDonald's so you
don't think that would be like awesome
and warm I think maybe yeah in the right
yard I think it would look very you
could need a really big yarn I don't
think you need like I don't think you
could have like a uh like one of those
blocks where there's a house next to a
house next door in my head right now is
I'm thinking of Q's backyard
I think it would look cool how funny
would it be if someone was able to erect
that in his or someone draw without them
knowing and then they come home and it's
in the yard it's a big swing because
it's going to be it's gonna be uh an
arduous task and an expensive one at
that I don't think it'd be that
expensive you have to excavate and drive
and and then transport a 40-foot steel
pole to the yard and then drive it into
the ground then make sure it's secure in
in literally in a logistical sense sure
and then probably run some electric to
it and then hope it doesn't fall in the
person's house by the way but not that
sign that's not the sign look at that
McPlay place did you see yeah yeah it
was crazy it looks like a goddamn
like six flags
that shine not the sign on the actual
building
the red thing that looks like the fries
with the M on top of it
you mean like the like like the steel
like like a like this like the sign on a
pole outside yeah
do you think I should ask you
you know McDonald's side if and when you
yeah that one
that one down down down down down
that yeah that's just like drive through
you don't think that'll be difficult do
you understand how much money and
Manpower that would take if I look it up
you would need a [__] freight train
if I look it up and I can afford it
if it's not crazy what happened to that
one's there's only one Arch on that one
that's the original
um there were that was that was do you
ever see the founder no that was the one
was it in St Louis or something that was
the Prototype they made one of those and
like the original one of the original
McDonald's is two of those signs and
then somebody was like oh the M they
separated the Arches it was always the M
but they separated like I think that's
just one of the original Arches from the
original McDonald's or whatever but the
I swear to God if I look it up and it's
not that expensive I'm going to ask you
if he would allow me to pay to have it
put it it will be expensive he will not
let you and you will not want him
no I think he's crazy enough I think
he's crazy enough you go yeah maybe if
it was like a billboard for Superman or
something there's no way he's putting
that in his yard but I will tell you by
the way is there anything worse of a
drop-off I don't mean to cut you off is
there anything worse of a drop off than
that McDonald's sign that says drive
through the fun the inviting Allure Of
It Whatever is there any worse drop-off
than that to the mick Cafe sign the most
Bland like Yuppie looking ugh yeah they
really they really tried to latch on to
something with the McCafe oh God I
remember in the late 90s they went
friends I tried to make it look like
friends I remember in the late 90s Cafe
wasn't a term that ran rampant in uh
in like the restaurant business cafes
like the term Cafe and the idea and
concept of a cafe
burst onto the scene in the 90s it might
have had to do with friends
but um I remember because I remember all
these businesses kept popping up in my
neighborhoods and we had never heard of
it and like this place Luna Cafe open
right and that's that's been there for
30 years now and then this and that and
I remember I worked at a place called
Classic Pizza
and the family owned a few chains and
like different cousins like owned each
one and the one that was opening out on
the other side of the island he was
going to call it Classic Pizza Cafe
because he said Cafe is all anybody
wants these days now it blew up and then
McDonald's tried to I gotta tell you
Classic Pizza Cafe sounds like a fun
time to me
those three words together it was on a
corner and it was on a main it was on
Main Street all right it's fun it's fun
McCafe that bothered me but wait but
back to my McDonald's history yeah I
remember the first time I had chicken
McNuggets ever
yeah backseat of my parents car my
friend Frankie
yeah my friend Frankie genre
episode I've heard Frankie janardi got
him and handed me one and it who died I
was like what is going on tonight you
had a chicken nugget uh so I don't think
I I don't think I don't think I never
had a piece of fried chicken I had fried
chicken I don't think I ever did maybe
you're right maybe I don't know maybe
they chicken fingers weren't popular
like no no yeah the uh I remember the
first Captain it came on it was lights
out I didn't want anything but that the
first Happy Meals were was the plastic
like submarine game changing
life-changing birthday party there every
year and then but here's the thing in
high school I gotta go I like this guy
in high school uh James pinkstone who I
believe I mentioned on this show like
Stone opinion you've met Pig Stone
remember my friend Pig pink his last
name is p i n k s t o n yes pink and
stone two words put together yeah you
met him he was my friend that came up
and we did that we hopped around to a
bunch of bars summer day whatever b-day
it was it was a bunch of us and we just
went we started at the Barcade yes
whatever you met him anyway when I when
I became best friends with him in high
school he also loved McDonald's
and we did a thing where every time we
had a half day on a Friday which was
often in Catholic High School
we would go to McDonald's and it was
back then you went to Catholic High
School yeah back then the um don't skirt
past it I didn't know that I just don't
want to digress past the story we won't
but I'll tell you but I did too we
should talk about that okay
um back then the two cheeseburger value
meal which was the King value meal
lights out it was 2.99.99 I thought yeah
299 yeah 299 that's what a medium soda
and small fry right yeah it was amazing
yeah I mean you got yeah you show me
more value you can't tell me where
there's more value or you can't it was
real meal for value
they invented the value meal and These
Guys these guys have broken ground in
ways that nobody has anyway
we would do this thing where it was it
was every other time the the one of us
had to buy for the other guy it was
called the three bucks
so we'd go and you go the three bucks is
on your side and the so that was a
tradition through my high school
so dude McDonald's like from age four or
five through high school and did you
ever like was a constant tradition okay
did you was it just like any fast food
or were you like loyal like if you if
you went to Burger King it was fine you
still got the Burger King toy you still
sat in Burger King it just Burger King
was a nice Wendy's was a nice like
diversion no I liked it all right you
weren't hating no no but I love but
McDonald's was King
well well
okay okay
uh Burger King was a nice treat I felt
like I was going over the neighbor's
house for a minute Burger King when did
they when did when did bring out the
king and make him like this weird
character that people thought was like
like funny and campy and mischievous and
stuff because when we were little I
don't know if he was like I believe he
was in I believe there was a cartoon
King when we were little but when we got
older was when they started doing that
like plastic head King which is
terrifying yeah it was terrifying right
it was like Frankie dude yeah but Burger
King was fun because they give you the
paper crowns
remember that do they still do it I
think you can still get it if you ask
but like I'll tell you another thing I
think Burger King did that McDonald's
may not have
a four pack of crayons and a placemat to
color on uh I think McDonald's did that
if you think it was Burger King's Jam
dude I think that there was a Burger
King set of four crayons
I mean dude here's the thing man you
know it was the 80s I like nice touches
like that so shout out to any restaurant
that gives you crayons Denny's was big
with that yeah Denny's was big of the
crowd shout out to crayons and placemats
I agree but I mean dude I'll tell you it
was like
people don't understand like if you were
born in the mid 90s on
on from there
you don't know man it's like like fast
food places they had like they had like
a a
they had a vibe
like they had a Vibe like now they're
they're very sterile it's very just like
you know the food tastes still the same
it's still pretty good
but like they had a Vibe like like there
were colors Associated like Burger King
was orange and brown that was their
color scheme and there were and it was
wood grain and whatever remember the old
school yeah it was awesome like we
talked before on here about the sit down
Pizza Huts you went in it was all like
that deep red vinyl it was dark yeah
there was the the hanging lamp each
Place had its own Aesthetics it was
Vibes man like and it was like its own
weird little experience and also Taco
Bells like like that that there's like
that website of like uh of converted
Taco Bells or whatever yeah where it's
like Taco Bell they all had the same
shape building where it looked like
looks like a mission or something it was
like a little like uh yeah it looked
like the Alamo or something
[Laughter]
time castle Burger King found fully
intact behind a wall at a Delaware mall
holy [__] that old school with the pink
leather the pink leather that's wild but
even that that's like 90s yeah that's
still new uh the thing is another thing
is like oh yeah Burger King Burger King
also had fake plants yes yes I remember
that and that was a thing like the vibe
the decor of the place
weirdly reflected the flavors of the
food
like Burger King definitely had a like
warmer
like Cozier feel like the taste of the
food is smokier it's you know flame
broiled all that [__] sesame seed
bun yeah and and the colors in there
reflected that McDonald's was to me was
more like it was like cartoony and like
popped like you know boom red ketchup
bang you know like it was like and
that's what it felt like in there when
you went in
I I always said to pink stone I go
McDonald's is cartoon food that's what I
love about it like it's like it's they
make it in a way where it's like this is
like a hamburger that I picture like
like Tom and Jerry eating yeah yeah yeah
like I can't like it's it's anyway
that's just that's where it got its
hooks in ball pits are so dirty it's
dangerous scientists find a single
plastic Bowl could have thousands of
germ cells like pneumonia sepsis and
meningitis I mean public ball pits are
notorious hiding places for children's
accidents frisky teenagers and foreign
and objects you telling someone me
someone got a handy under the balls I
guess so I'm not surprised it is weird
if a teenager is under the balls and
there's kids in there I mean it's odd
yeah but maybe if you hit the right hour
at night and you're there with a gal and
you jump in and you just do a quick I
don't know I never I never imagined
semen I'll tell you this is why kids
probably got less sick back then because
kids are jumping in researchers at the
University of North Georgia tested balls
from pits at six physical therapy
centers they found 31 different kinds of
bacteria that can cause skin eye heart
blood and lung infections as well as
sepsis anonia meningitis cleaning
practices for pulpits are not
standardized but the new studies
suggests they should be no [__]
always do a study like this but here's
the thing they always do a study like
this and say these things nobody [__] is
a kid going I got sepsis from the ball
pit
dude I mean
is there a confirm if you think about it
how could they have been allowed right
now we have health department ratings
that we didn't have back then the health
department raids your establishment if
you're a food establishment and ranks it
from a b c d fail you have to have a
passing grade they give you
there's no way those could exist in
today's day and age how could they put
imagine a ball pit that was there for
let's just call it 10 years
uncleaned
[Music]
what were we thinking and how could
people let their kids go in here's my
point do you know any kids that had
sepsis I don't know
specifically but do you ever do you know
any kids
one my dad had pneumonia once what
happened man I can't I'd suffer from a
ball pit I'm sure it happened I mean you
know I'm sure my point is is look you
lick one of those Bulls is getting sick
I mean look what idiot kid you're an
idiot enough of a kid to lick one of the
balls first of all I mean you as an
adult I mean a kid's licking the balls
if the kids that sounded terrible I
never did I knew better if the kid's
young enough they're gonna bite the ball
throw it away but let's lick the ball
but you're gonna remember that dude yeah
the pirate yeah he's great oh he had to
go ahead oh there's a pirate ship too it
was like a watchtower I forgot about
that you would go head first into the
balls but I mean dive in like it was the
ocean the ball you're just diving into
it yeah okay I mean did you did you I
get it but did you ever get the Grimace
prison it was all little prisons
oh was it a was it a Grimace prison too
you could look it's like bars I mean it
was just so you could see it fall out
yeah but it was like it's funny that
they didn't paint the bars purple
because like it would have matched at
least maybe there was like a rule that
you weren't allowed to it was like a
safety rule or something a couple things
one I think that when you throw a party
at McDonald's at least for a certain
amount of time I think that the
characters were included I mean if you
had to I I think if you had to play
place then that's that's good enough but
like for me the big calling card was
Ronald makes an appearance we should we
like it blew your balls off we should do
that this year for my birthday we we
dropped the ball last year we should do
it this year I'll tell you what we
should just do it did I tell you what we
did in college what uh once a year we
had
um
we had we went to Burger King on uh
Tyson's Lane and Highland Boulevard of
Staten Island we went to Burger King and
we printed up menus we printed menus up
and then we went and we put white
tablecloths on all the tables salt and
pepper shakers and we put um candles and
then we had we had people put on like a
uniform like a top like a tux and we had
people come over and give us the menus
take our order then go and there's a
McDonald's downtown that does that
really ourselves there's like just what
you would buy all the food and bring it
home and then do this no no no we turned
the Burger King to our own personal
restaurant they would the Bergen would
let you do that yeah there's there's a
McDonald's in pimp look up Manhattan
fancy McDonald's there's a McDonald's in
New York McDonald's on Broadway I think
it's 24 hours and two floors has a baby
grand piano in it that a guy plays
that's that's the fancy McDonald's yeah
is it still open
look concierge it said
you called them concierge once and I
went off on yeah I know
uh including the saddest McDonald's in
the world
the saddest one has to be the one next
to the cellar right
right click on the one that says it's
the link that says are they calling this
this
what is that H Street where is that
I look like 8th Street
oh because there's too much violence oh
yeah oh is that the yeah the Eighth
Avenue yes I'm anything
uh okay wait go back to the fancy
McDonald's real quick is it still open
that's not the same one I'm talking
about
I'm talking about
Maybe
Soho
I thought there was one downtown no yeah
there's there's one the one you're
talking about is downtown they have like
tablecloths
fanciest McDonald's we've ever seen
oh Factor thank you factory for
sponsoring the show it is prime spring
season and you're going to need some
wholesome convenient meals to energize
you for this warmer more active day
activity that you're going to be getting
into and you want to keep track of
reaching your goals Factor America's
number one ready to eat meal kit can
help you fuel up fast with ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
you're going to save time you're going
to eat well you're going to tackle
everything on your to-do list yeah it's
it's a it's a service I use
um it's a subscription service so it
comes every week you can pick your own
meals or they come pick them for you and
they have all sorts of proteins and
different categories like keto and
calorie smart veggie uh they arrange
from like 400 calories maybe 380 to like
600. the thing I love about them Joe
is every single what it was just funny
every single one of them is two minutes
yes exactly two minutes in the microwave
and they are like they're not frozen
they're fresh made and like if you're
hungry you're eating in two minutes if
you're in a rush you're eating in two
minutes and I love the fact that the
portion control is done for you because
I feel satiated because they have
protein in there but I don't overeat I
agree 100 uh and I like that factor is
uh making uh sustainable Decisions by
the way they offset 100 of delivery
emissions to your door they Source 100
renewable electricity for the production
sites and offices and they feature
sustainably sourced Seafood in the meals
Factor's just great all around so do
your thing go get some Factor no prep No
Mess two minutes ready head to
factormeals.com taste buds five zero
you're going to use code taste buds five
zero and get 50 off your first box
that's code taste buds five zero at
factormeals.com tastebuds50 to get fifty
percent off your first Betsy vessi Vesti
in a world where most people complain
about the rain
here comes the rain again Annie Lennox
I'm Only Happy When It Rains that's not
a complaint but still it's somebody that
knows Shirley Manson the rain is coming
yes vesi is here to believe there's a
bright side to the wet weather and
that's the type of shoes they are
providing for you yeah they hard Flex
with waterproof technology that is their
own it's proprietary it's great and I
love it I got a pair of vestes in the
mail me too and I opened them up I'm
like I normally I'm a sneaker guy and I
normally like very particular about my
shoes
I tried them on I was like not only are
they waterproof they literally were so
comfortable I gave my dad a pair and
then I ordered the boots myself and
what's really cool uh Betsy has created
a product that lets you thrive in water
okay uh while also supporting
organizations that protect and create it
uh I like these shoes because they're
comfortable they're stylish they slip
right on super fast and they let you
keep moving in the rain you're not
afraid if you step in the puddle you're
not afraid if the drops start coming
down again you're thriving in the water
it's awesome they're 100 waterproof
proof not resistant lightweight Comfort
all right four-way stretch uh they're
they they they're they're malleable as
they say uh versatile they're easy to
clean they're super easy to clean which
is great because sometimes when you're
in the rain also comes the mud vetsi is
great so experience the bright side of
wet weather uh and take advantage of
vesi's huge Memorial Day sale going on
vessi.com taste buds you're going to
save 30 percent off your order that's
v-e-s-s-i.com taste buds
to save 30 off your order today don't
wait too long to grab your favorite
vessi shoes because this sale ends soon
no that's not it the Times Square one I
used to call it Fortress McDonald's it
had like steel walls and stuff the Times
Square One is awesome that's that's
that's not it though that's the Times
Square one that's that's not it um did
you buy like even one share of
McDonald's stock just just to say you're
a partial owner I mean you know at this
at this stage I probably should but did
you ever did you dream as well did you
dream your whole life to have a ball pit
in your house or no is that just me did
you did you no Mike you never did Pimp
no no my dream it was my dream from a
kid first time I ever saw a ball pit I
said I'm gonna have that one day and I
don't know if you watch architectural
digest Open Door series you may have
talked about this
there's a model an actress I guess Carla
Delevingne I think her name is I might
be saying it wrong she uh her house she
built the ball pit in her house I and I
was like son of a [__]
I uh my dream was always 80s arcade in
my house same and I started doing it
when I lived in L.A by buying machines
and then the machine what about a ball
pit do you love it's so much one as long
as it it's it's you know in discounting
of the germs I've never loved the ball
pit it is it's like a different way to
submerge yourself and feel like are you
seeing this this look at this McDonald's
are you seeing this look at this pip you
got to put pictures of this that can't
be real this is real I'm telling you
I've been hearing about this for years I
can't believe I never went I don't know
why
the guy's in a suit and she's in a gown
yeah they break the waiter
and they played it how have I never gone
wait is that on is that on a paper plate
yes
upscale you served it on a paper plate
oh it's right here we should do it we
should do it we should do like a
Excursion for the pot bring the green
the camera okay
all right um okay so you never wanted a
ball pit have to do this you think I'm
crazy if I put a ball pit in my house no
would you get how you gonna keep it
clean you just read the sepsis thing we
don't have little kids
I look I think it's all trust me
it'll be clean
I mean but would you guys jump in it
right the expense have you ever see us
of course I would jump in do you have a
ball pit too I can't remember something
had a some department store had a ball
pit not McDonald's I think it was my
maybe it was Ikea it is right I think
Ikea had one listen of course I would
jump in it I wouldn't be worried about
germs I'm saying to you you want to
accrue the cost of getting that cleaned
once a week
I put all the plastic bowls in a couple
of garbage bags I put them outside I
hose them down do you know the amount of
time and effort that's going to take all
right then I hire a cleaning service to
come in and clean the bowls
I think it's gonna I think that's a
heftier cost than you think it's going
to be dude I I think that's a hefty car
I think so I think it's just a matter of
like I could I could even throw them in
the washing machine
nuts don't melt you can't do that I feel
like there's a way to clean them
there's definitely a way I'm
I'm sorry I'll I'll Outsource that I
think the real question is are you gonna
have a slide
it's a must yeah I I would say if you
can do it and it doesn't ruin your life
to maintain it yeah and then yes I'll
tell you something right now I don't
want to be I don't want to keep time
with someone that if there was a ball
pit in front of them they they would not
jump in it that's how I those if you're
not someone that has to jump in a ball
pit on site
upon sight I don't want you in my life
fair enough I can't argue that I can't I
see a ball pit
I literally have to be physically
restrained okay because I will run and
jump in it all right and if there's a
kid under the balls I didn't know about
it's going to be curtains curtains for
the child oh that's so interesting there
were urban legends about kids being
killed or injured by vipers hanging in
the ball pit that's why jackass did that
in in the movie they did the Vipers or
the anacondas in the ball I heard about
the needle I didn't realize that was
actually based on something I didn't
either that's terrifying
you know you release a Viper in a ball
pit and jump in and just see what
happens I love that you're in the middle
of Jersey and somebody has a Viper
it's so crazy all right we gotta we
should get to the battle
um today's battle is
oh so and by the way I don't have kovid
feeling sick yesterday was apparently
just a fall off of the allergies
uh it just went away eventually and I
feel 100 today so I'm okay
um anyway
here we go it's a good move our battle
today you gonna come on the cruise
yeah send me off would you like to send
me off yes
yeah of course I'm gonna come on the
cruise uh the Impractical Jokers are
doing a cruise our fifth cruise with
Eric Andre it's January 22nd to the 26th
2024 going from I believe Miami to the
Bahamas are you filming on there
um we we have on three of the four of
them so it's TBD but it has been floated
do we want to film on there and Eric
Andre is going to be on it with you Eric
Andre is throwing it with us he's he's
literally the other co-host of it let's
do it we had a big call yesterday about
uh a bunch of like the stuff we're gonna
do it was crazy but you both taste buds
came up yeah I was gonna so let's do it
we we should do a live tickets are on
tickets are on sale right now and
practical jokers cruise I think it's
cold or get ship faced get shipface.com
the boats already have sold out on every
sale I'm not trying to write any checks
here but I was going to say of course it
will be fun to do right let's 100 want
to do it both you q and Eric have said
at separate times to me are you gonna
come on the cruise yeah I'm gonna come
on Cruz let's get the paperwork done
let's sort it out
I can't wait dude and how fun would it
be if we were able to do a live taste
buds on this thing yeah how fun would
that and how many there'll be at least a
dozen other Comics there we could have
like I had a blast on the Joker's Cruise
the first time yeah uh all right
yeah yes I'm in let's do it okay all
right here we go today
uh we're doing peppermint versus
butterscotch candies hard candy uh hard
candies basically and I I'd say this
will drift a little bit into the flavors
themselves right sure no but but yeah
basically it's it's grandmother's purse
to my mouth from God to God's ears uh
the butterscotch versus The Peppermint I
am team butterscotch salad team
peppermint and it's time to
b-a-t-t-l-e butts all right
uh I'm in such a good mood I didn't want
to do the yeah
and I also didn't feel a need to do and
I love you chance I'm with you yeah all
right that's a good mood that's the mood
I'm in yeah uh all right uh I'm gonna
start by saying this I don't want to
divert us anymore but did I ever tell
you about peppermint Gummy Bear the drag
queen that I befriended 30 years ago I
thought I swear to God I thought you
were saying peppermint flavored Gummy
Bears I was gonna barf
peppermint gummy bear when you said it's
the name of a drag queen could be the
greatest drag queen name I've ever heard
in my life yes so so so I I definitely
told this story pimpy it might have been
on hey babe
but I'll make it quick but it just it's
it's appropriate
so this person is now famous I met this
person in the year 2000
23 years later
oh he he is he I believe he's a drag
queen so he
um is like the the like a RuPaul level
figurehead spokesperson for the drag
queen Community especially in New York
um I was at a nightclub
and I met this this guy I I his name's
Kevin actually and uh and he was with a
girl and all my friends were there and I
was having a house party the next night
because my my parents are going on
vacation and I was having one of those
Humdinger House parties where like what
happened was some friends came over
early and we removed the furniture from
the home oh wow we put all the furniture
from the house in my sister's bedroom
like Jenga well how old are you at this
point I was um
I was uh 25 23. okay
23 something like that I don't it was
two thousand two thousand uh two
something like that okay
and so we met these people and we hung
out with them all night right and he
wasn't dressed in Drag and they were
really fun they say I said look I'm
having a house party tomorrow you guys
want to come they were from another
Borough and so I gave them directions
and they took like literally the bus to
the trains of the [__] Ferry and they
came to my house okay so
he says to me would you mind if I bring
a friend and I say no as long as you I
just met these two people right and they
seem very nice I don't know but I was
like sure just you know no problem but
just make sure they're good people
the next day my friends come we remove
all the furniture we all chip in money
we go to the liquor store we get like as
much liquor as we can afford we get like
the strobe lights we hang sheets to
block out the windows yeah turn those
lights on all three floors in my parents
house I had about 50 people 60 people in
there right and I was it was a pajama
party so everyone came in pajamas and
whoever wanted to crash crash like like
20 people crashed it was one of those
things where people are laying on the
floor right it wasn't debauchery it was
fun right good people
the doorbell rings
at like
two hours into the party right and I
told my friends I met this guy and this
girl last night they're gonna come hang
you know just make them feel welcome
I opened the door and there's a drag
queen at the door and it's him
and I guess his koi way of saying can I
bring a friend was just like
cutesy way of saying I'm gonna come and
drag okay and he brought the girl the
girl was so cute too I had a little
crush on her but uh I was just like and
he was like hello you know and I'm like
oh my God he's like I'm peppermint gummy
bear
and he had he he had on a full outfit
and they walked in everyone was like
what the hell imagine
a drag queen walks into
a a a a a a a pajama house party at full
when it's at its full strength it just
amped everybody up everyone starts going
nuts everyone just starts dancing with
them I love him he tells me would you
mind if I go into the bathroom and
change into something more comfortable I
said go ahead he goes into the bedroom
he comes out in an even more outrageous
outfit hot pink leather pleather outfit
with with uh what do you call those
shoes uh no
you know the shoes that are like
platforms yeah he was already told he
came out he's like seven feet tall and
he's just walking around my house they
stayed the whole night till the break of
dawn and then I drove them back to the
ferry at like 7 A.M holy [__] I I turned
out a month later I'm at a nightclub
again I met him at this club called om a
couple months later I'm at Limelight
I used to go you know I used to be into
that never My Scene
It was short-lived but it was fun I'm on
stage I'm on the stage dancing which you
know the stage was open everybody so the
stage was crowded the dancer was crowded
and he across the room all the way
another side dance floor I see him
because he's like a foot tall and
everyone else and he sees me
in the middle of Limelight and he just
yells and he's known there he's a
fixture there apparently the place parts
he walks through the net so it gets on
stage comes hugs me gives you a big kiss
and we start dancing and the whole place
is like what the [__] is going on that's
awesome right
20 I'll never forget the guy
a year or two ago I'm like I wonder if
this guy like I was like I just typed in
peppermint gummy bear but he shortened
it to just peppermint he is literally an
icon that's awesome right now I don't
know if you don't remember he has to
remember me
we have to reach out to him get him on
Facebook yeah yeah I love it I'll reach
out to him he has to remember me because
it was such a unique experience I'm
sorry for the diversion it's okay but um
but that was that was a fun little story
yeah
um all right
your team peppermint I'm team
butterscotch I will start by saying this
as far
back as I can remember I always want to
be a gangster I mean look butterscotch
it's it's it's it's the OG I mean it's
it is it's the it's the first before
there was candy and a guy said I I have
invented candy it was butter I'd be
interested to know though because
peppermint peppermint hard candy has
also got to be from the from the
beginning according to Folklore in
167 but stress folklore in that sentence
the choir Master at the Cologne
Cathedral in Cologne Germany was
searching for a way in which to quiet
Restless children during Christmas Eve
Mass he asked the local candy maker to
create
what were then referred to as sugar
sticks to eat during the service to keep
well that's the invention of the candy
cane peppermint candy no no that's the
invention of the candy cane Christmas
Eve Mass sugar sticks peppermint that's
that's got to be what that is now [__] I
forgot about candy canes well boy you
got me there
because I can't think of well I fairly
won't put candy cane into this I'm
talking about the plastic wrapped Bowl
dish of hard candy that is the direct
competitor to the butterscotch I will
here's is in candy here's the thing with
peppermint for me okay I like peppermint
I'm fine with peppermint it freshens
your breath I think it's great I enjoy
the flavor however peppermint to me is
only serves only serves that purpose it
is a means to freshen your breath
butterscotch like if we were trapped in
this room for weeks
or days and we were like dude we're
going to starve to death in here and we
scrounged up butterscotch candies I
would actually feel like I ate I would
that to me almost feels like a food
instance some kind of substance
peppermint I don't care what shape or
form you put it in it will never ever
feel like sustenance to me ever in a
million years it is it's toothpaste
flavor it's it's flavored it's it's a
freshener that's well I mean only
because I'm of the age I'm at now the
peppermint for weeks for sustenance
would cause me tremendous heartburn sure
but other than that I would say that
butterscotch
is is good I don't dislike butterscotch
but butterscotch butterscotch also a
great drag name you're right
son of a [__]
um well that'll be a house
um I think butterscotch though yeah
butterscotch is the name of the greatest
beatboxer I've ever seen really this
young woman named butterscotch
I so Rozelle who's amazing I was about
the person I was told
uh Roselle was in a group called peeping
Tom started founded by Mike Patton from
Faith No More yeah Mike Patton's one of
my favorite musicians ever Faith No More
is one of my favorite bands ever I love
all his bands but anyway he had a band
called peeping Tom and Roselle was in it
and I saw them I sometimes live they're
great in Central Park there they were
great but one time when I saw them razel
wasn't there and instead they had this
girl shot him and I was like oh man
Roselle's on here and then he gave the
stage over to butterscotch at one point
and I was like they're not gonna put
someone up there she has to fill in for
Rozelle that's not gonna be skilled she
was like it was like mind-blowing yeah
hours it has to be put into that it's so
nuts well that what's his face from uh
from uh freestyle love uh Shockwave he's
really good yeah
um anyway rocket money rocket get money
rocket money I love these guys they're
with us like every week thank you for
supporting our pod rocket money and I
love I love what you offer I mean I I
use it I use it all
the time I have my lady using it I got
my mom to use it especially my parents
because like what this is is it's it's
an app that basically finds out all of
your outstanding subscriptions that you
have out there that you may not know
about put some in one place yes okay and
then it's an Aggregate and then you can
cancel right there with the click of a
button instead of trying to remember
who you have a subscription with how
much is it is it reoccurring did you get
canceled what do you have to even do to
cancel that thing sometimes they make
you write a
sometimes they make you write a a letter
like it has to be like fresh ink letters
yeah it's like sometimes you want to
cancel like a streaming service and it's
like trying to unsubscribe from a gym
membership which is a personal finance
app that puts it all in one place 80 of
people forget about their subscription
yeah it's true uh uh rocket money will
quickly and easily find those
subscriptions for you and for any uh
that you don't want or you don't want to
pay for anymore you just hit cancel as
Sal said rocket money is going to cancel
it for you it's that easy over three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to 720 a
year and one other thing is uh you can
also manage all your finances in one
place can automatically categorize your
expenses so you can keep track of your
budgets in real time so stop throwing
your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
taste buds that's rocketmoney.com
tastebuds rocketmoney.com taste buds
babes I love it too I am filming my
special at the Vic in Chicago on
December 1st and 2nd and thus I am also
kicking off a tour I will be all over
the place Bowling Green Kentucky
Cincinnati Ohio Toledo Wilkes-Barre
Wilmington Delaware Torrington
Connecticut uh Macon Georgia
Savannah Georgia Athens Georgia Peoria
Rockford Springfield Olen Illinois
Duluth Appleton Rochester Minnesota uh
I'm gonna be all over I'm gonna be uh
like I said in Hartford and I'm going to
be in Syracuse doing some clubs and some
theaters that'll all be announced very
very soon but if you want to see me
right away you just see me on tour with
the guys in practicaljokerslive.com uh
this weekend coming up we're on Columbus
Cleveland Detroit then Minneapolis Des
Moines Kansas City now we close out in
Nashville Indianapolis and St Louis all
those tickets are on sale right now at
impracticaljokerslive.com
butterscotch right
um what is what is butterscotch
comprised of It's Not Butter and scotch
why is it called butterscotch well it's
funny because Scotch does have a
butterscotch flavor to it it could be
buttery I suppose
one one is its obvious connection to the
country of Scotland buttery toffee is
sometimes called butterscotch and other
another that the word Scotch was derived
from Scorch Scorch the word butterscotch
was first recorded in Doncaster a
Yorkshire Yorkshire city in England who
began making candy 18 and I gotta say so
this peppermint came first these are
both Foods by the way these are both
Foods that when you take them I'll say
this when you take these Foods out of
their candy form or these flavors excuse
me out of their candy form and Infuse
them in other ways
I don't like it
I think mint chocolate chip ice cream is
disgusting I had two nights ago from it
makes me sick I think I think mint iced
tea is revolting
um but and I don't like Scotch the
liquor Scotch I like whiskey I can't
stand scotch and one of the reasons is
because it tastes too much like
butterscotch but I will say this I like
I like but the butterscotch is a flavor
of something has more use to me than
peppermint does like if you gave me ice
cream with butterscotch syrup I'd be
like okay this is pretty good peppermint
ice cream I can't tell you how gross I
think that is it doesn't matter that's
literally it has nothing to do with this
battle
butterscotch you have one it's Pleasant
after one I don't want another I've had
enough of the feeling and taste of
butterscotch okay I I'm not gonna go
ahead and say it's an old people candy
it is I see its value outside of senior
citizens
but
sorry I'm sorry good I just saw Jeremy
write peppermint candy equals Christmas
candy equals funerals
you know you know like um
we were just at a birthday party the
other night actually this is where this
came from actually yes we were at we
were at Chase birthday party yes and the
theme was old because he he's getting
older and so they had fun stuff that had
to do with that demon at every table was
a bowl of butterscotch candies those
little strawberry candies yes and mints
and that's where we got the battle from
oh those
yeah now I will tell you though that a
lot of times when there's a bowl of
candy these are to be chosen from and I
will always choose the mint because the
mint has more value to me even if I
don't want to have it right then I'm
like oh let me take a mint and put it in
my pocket and put in my bag because at
some point this mint will literally
serve a purpose for me is it tasty yes
do I want to suck on it all day no but
if I'm gonna have one of the mints why
not also completely it's a breath
freshener that's so that's my point
though that's what it is right because
of peppers because the candy cane is not
a breath freshener but if your face I I
can't tell you the last time I've had a
candy cane I can't tell you the last
time I've wanted a candy cane you don't
have at least one candy cane per
Christmas
read my lips useless to me
I'm gonna brush my teeth and then I'll
eat cookies I mean what are we doing
here it's Christmas I like sucking on
the candy cane uh until the the red goes
away and it's just white and then if and
then it forms like a sharp edge that you
can use as a ship
do you never did that let me tell you I
one time oh my God it's so sharp I
actually I actually cut skin yeah all
right the only candy cane grocery to me
than the regular candy this is a [__]
I know Cherry one the rainbow the Cherry
one makes me is that the rainbow one
Whatever whatever the one that's like
green and red and it tastes like fruit
no the one that's so the one that's the
full rainbow is gross I don't there's
one that's meant to taste like cherry
and it's disgusting it's disgusting you
know I choked on a butterscotch candy
when I was young at the doctor's office
right I told you that I know like a kid
that licks balls
they had they had a basket there it's
just sad for kids to that was that was
the point of it right it just said they
invented it as a way for kids to calm
down when they're I ate a butterscotch
candy I was playing in the waiting room
and I started choking I think I told
this story too but whatever
um I started choking and I was with my
mom who's already
a warrior and she's like oh my God and
like the nurses or whatever the behind
the counter that there when you check in
at the doctor they just like froze and
didn't do anything and I was like I
remember and a hefty woman
a brick [__] House of a woman stood up
and just came at me she was like Mrs
what's the person from Matilda I don't
know Mrs Trumbull she just came at me
and she went and she swooped down and
her grabbed my ankles with her two hands
and then had the confidence that she had
the strength to lift me by the ankles in
one clean jerk like that my head
wouldn't swing down and hit the ground
she lifted me right up and then like a
cartoon
by my ankles like a [__] cartoon I
was upside down flailing and the candy
came out and then my mother started
screaming at the nurses freezing and
she's like this woman has to hang him
upside down while you watch we're at the
doctor
it
would have been so great
if you died
[Music]
because this insane method just didn't
work I know she would look so crazy with
a dead kid by the ankles
mother go what are you doing
I gotta I gotta remember to write this
could be a bit I could tell the story
this story is crazy
oh my God can I tell you
I've never had that happen to me again
because it's a very unique situation I
choked on a uh but you never had someone
grab you by the ankles and shake-ups I
choked on a mint
peppermint lifesaver
uh as a kid a breath saver a breath
saver okay what are you doing here I got
a heartburn from the Celsius I just
drank I'm gonna take uh all right
fantastic give it one second let me just
you know
give it a second I mean this is come on
this is Bush League here what are you
doing
oh my God
all right all right here's my I choked
on a mint Lifesaver and my pop-up who
lived with us when I was a little kid
this was when I was in the first grade
picked me up
by the stomach
like hoisted me and did the Heimlich to
me he knew how he just he just flew by
the seat of his pants he knew how he
picked me up from behind and got me up
and went and dude it shot out of my
my map my throat with a trajectory you
could have taken an eye out with it like
wow it was crazy how I guess you have a
choke on candy no but I give a joke I
had to save Chaz from choking Chaz
palmitary he was shot candy even though
he's choking on a chicken cutlet it was
just me and him
pray to God
no he didn't yeah he went like this to
you and he couldn't breathe and he was
like he was making weird sounds and I
was watching him die and I was really
high so I didn't know what to do
so I just kind of dry humped him and
eventually
holy [__] somebody has to animate that
somebody has to animate that no we were
having lunch between pods
he's oh my god dude do you understand
that yo you might you might be how many
people on the planet 8 billion you might
be one of eight billion that can say
Chaz Paul material she was choking on a
chicken cutlet and I saved his life by
humping him and I'll never forget he
kind of threw up a little in the sink
and he said that was the worst form I've
ever experienced apparently he chokes
often form the worst wait wait I'm sorry
the first thing this is your
responsibility this guy's choking
himself left and right it's your problem
because he paid for lessons
what he he did yeah hold on
how the [__] how do you not hold on it's
a full pot episode how do you also two
how is this please write this down we
need to get child's pulmonary on taste
buds uh yeah he'll come I mean we've got
to get him on taste buds and talk to him
we have to
do an Italian Dish yeah yeah
that'd be fun yes and on location
wait the first thing he did after you
ostensibly you saved his life was
critique and criticized the form you
used not a thank you there was a thank
you after that
that's so fun and we went right back to
pod and he never that is chaos that is
chaos
chokes on the reg yeah he had uh well he
was offered Tony Soprano and he had to
turn it down because he had throat
cancer okay and so after the treatments
his throat is short
so oh well Tony Soprano he's got short
throat all right no I never heard of it
uh could you imagine I didn't wow he was
he wow imagine me standing there with
him dead and what what does that look
like I don't know
uh it doesn't look good yeah those look
good for you I changed I cut your
podcast producing uh work in half
probably you know also probably would be
the probably the most famous person to
die from choking since Mama Cass I would
I would argue that the guy choking on a
ham sandwich which I think is urban
legend but I often that's a terrible
headline Chad palmitary dies in choking
a chicken cutlet I'm embarrassed to
Memphis I often eat too fast without
chewing and get food stuck like here
where I have to like I'll if I drink
fluid to push it down like fluid will
back up in my throat and I will have to
go into a room throw the food up that
got stuck it's horrible it's happened to
me on dates like where I've had to go to
the bathroom and like and like the girl
will be like are you okay you were gone
for like 35 minutes
dude one time I had a girl really
embarrassed sitting on my couch and I
was in I have a studio apartment and the
kitchen was like that way but you
couldn't see the sink from the couch and
the whole place was like 300 square feet
and I felt so sick and nauseous and it
was at night and we were like sitting on
the couch like I think we were making
out or whatever and I was like oh hold
on I gotta go get something out of the
kitchen and I went into the kitchen
turned on turned on the sink and just
threw up in the sink and I tried to mask
it with the sound and then I still had
to throw up but I was taking too long so
mid throw up I popped my head out and be
like one second and then I went back and
threw up again and then I went into the
bathroom and brushed my teeth and I have
no idea if she knew that I threw up or
not but I threw up so much and she was
like seven feet away if it wasn't if it
wasn't for the noise there'd be no
embarrassment in throwing up
I don't know if you open your mouth and
all this [__] just spilled out of it in
silence that's still pretty bad
you go to the room and it's dead silent
oh inside if she doesn't know that's
what I'm saying if it wasn't for the
noise the only reason even if it wasn't
about the noise I get away with it
you're going um worried about you know
yeah it's because oh they might hear me
that's you know I wondered it also looks
crazy I just saw how recently at a party
and I always think do you know what did
she know I threw up that night we got to
go to the phones we're uh we're uh we're
out of time here this was a very
pleasant battle we didn't get a
Grandmom's energy there was a lot to
talk about we didn't really really dig
into this right now uh I I would say we
dug in as much as we could I my I stand
by I stand by what I said butterscotch
is a flavor itself has more uses than
peppermint butterscotch is a candy
itself that I I hard disagree with I
think he flipped that peppermint has way
more uses than butterscotch I I disagree
because I think any time it has a
Paramount use in my in my opinion
peppermint is a flavor in anything
outside of it mint is gross that's well
it's a good thing we'll talk about mints
so butterscotch
as a candy has more sustenance and more
purpose than a peppermint Peppermint's
only purpose is to serve as a breath
freshener
that's my final there's no sustenance in
butterscotch I'm just saying to me it's
a candy just like the event also I
didn't even get into the
chewable those the other ones other
peppermints that come in like a ball
that they like chalky the ones that like
have the consistency of the diner mints
which if you talk about the ball pit
being bad that Diner mint situation who
who you want to talk about disgusting
who's spreading more disease than a
peppermint dish I mean it's just it is
outrageous still do the peppermint dish
yes they do I haven't seen like you
touch it you're on with your own I think
it's like you turn it upside down it
falls in your hand I haven't seen the
open air peppermintation alone I was big
on Staten Island yeah yeah dude with the
spoon and then you just take it on the
way out huge I mean it was I used to
love it back then but then once I
realized oh no you shouldn't touched it
it was huge in Philly remember the
Seinfeld where he fills the napkin with
them yeah you're not too young for that
right no I remember that it might be
still happening now yeah I didn't even
touch on but you know the ones that are
wrapped like peppermint and they're red
and white but they're also chalky and
that you could like suck them they're
like they have that consistency that
that also kind of is it's in play it's a
rock peppermint candy what about
peppermint tea does that count here I
like peppermint tea
I don't know I think peppermint has way
more applications oh then butterscotch
everyone thinks that
except
um all right why doesn't why we got okay
okay we have to we have to why is it
without an insinuate that we have to one
second why does butterscotch not appeal
to young people and and but peppermint
does though peppermint then appeals to
all ages I think butterscotch really
just doesn't appeal to younger kids I
never hear of a young kid being like I
want a butterscotch
they don't want a peppermint either this
is Nana candy this is what we're saying
and what I'm saying is is as far as the
no and I disagree as a child
butterscotch I I enjoyed butterscotch
far more than I ever enjoyed peppermint
I'll give you this far more I'll give
you this I I do enjoy a butterscotch
dum-dum
what's a I don't even know what that is
you don't know what a dum-dum is oh the
lollipop yes of course butterscotch has
more practical purpose as a flavor than
peppermint it doesn't but I will say
dum-dums should be against something
dum-dums are iconic maybe Smarties do
you like Smarties I think Smarties are
arguably one of the worst candies that
has ever we don't we'll get into that
Smarties let's go straight into Humble
Pie okay let's go straight into Hubble
pie we're sorry guys we have to kind of
skip the phones but we're seeing a lot
of my Nana is not all around to to to to
to weigh in on this uh Humble Pie we've
got 4 600 votes uh and we'll give the
win to the Tweet we mentioned earlier
that was very funny uh follow that
person at can we put the address here
thanks pimp all right here we roll out
the percentages pimpy
oh
[Music]
twins at 58.2 percent the peppermint at
41 points I really really thought
that I would have that especially I
didn't think I'd lose by that much
damn I guess people do respect
butterscotch more than I thought I just
it's like I said I think people see
peppermint as one purpose and one
purpose we could have read some phones
to understand what the vibe was but uh
all right folks I still love you I love
you too don't forget Wednesday May 31st
moment dot CEO slash taste buds
taste buds be coming to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
them